[Music]
have been done by 10,000 squat challenge
well let's go crazy and this time we
want to do a 10,000 ad and squat
challenge in 30 days I guarantee you
your legs and your coal muscles will be
on fire and they will lean up okay ready
or not let's do it let's start with
basic squat okay I'm going to have mercy
on you so let's start with something
really easy to get your body warmed up
to begin with so stand sugar with a part
with your toes pointed forward and push
your butt back okay
so for each workout we want to do 30
repetitions ready let's go so basic
squat down and up okay very good so
remember push your butt back alright and
lift your chest up very good good you
can place both arms right in front of
you or you can place them right behind
your head all right very good
so choose your option nice and easy get
your legs warmed up and go deeper
alright squat deeper go down push up
with your use and go down good hands in
front
keep going very nice so remember to keep
your knees soft 10 more less than 10
right now keep going
very good so this is your first workout
you have five more okay let's go four
three two last one and good down onto
the mat for your first chord challenge
which will be Russian twists okay so
left and right is one alright good lift
your legs up very good so twist feel
your obliques working all right good if
you want to you can tap tap and tap good
so tighten the core muscles lift your
legs up if this is too hard then drop
your heels on the floor to begin with
very good keep going twist side to side
good your entire body should be in a
straight line and it should only be your
upper body twisting from side to side
ten more let's keep going very good last
few more
suck in those comas five more for last
three last two twists plus one and back
up into plie squat okay please God
point your toes out okay Stan what I
want you to tap the floor okay good
the moment you tap the floor that's how
low you should go good tap push your
butt back and feel your inner thighs
working good tap ok tap do not hunch
fall with this it's wrong okay
bring your back down tap ok tap bring
your butt down very good
feel the inner thighs working and your
outer glutes working as well good tap
and tap get do you feel those muscles
it's time to wade your leg muscles up
ten more gifts let's go nice eight
tap seven good six five plus four four
three two and one you know the drill
back it down onto the floor two bicycle
crunches okay left and right is one
let's go one two
imagine you're cycling three very good
twist for good kick it out five keep
going okay
point your toes and twist your oblique
muscles good lift your shoulders off the
floor very good okay the goal is to lift
your shoulders off the floor not just
moving your answer good point your toes
bring your knees in feel your lower abs
working view your co-working and good
keep cycling okay keep cycling and
remember pace your breathing last ten
one let's come together two three keep
pointing four
five last five more six seven eight and
we were to get back up and let's go
back up good we did plie squat let's go
into narrow squat legs together feet
together okay I want you to squat back
good point
back okay bring your ankles your toes
and your knees together and point back
very good
again you can place your arms in front
if you want to and remember the squat
low push up with the heels
squeeze you're good very good go deep
and go No nice squeeze and squeeze okay
so there are many variations to squats
depending on what squat you do it will
work on different muscles alright good
this will really work on your quads more
good keep going chest up
do not compromise your form okay do not
compromise your form
chest up last ten very good keep
squatting you can hear my breathing it's
going up very good
so your heart rate should be going up as
well that's five more five four
good three last two two and last one
let's get back down into mountain
climbers so in a plank position
remember left and right is one go one
doing just climb I want you to work your
legs work your core muscles and every
movement should have a purpose ok so
drive your knees into your chest
feel your core working good drive it in
good keep working you are doing very
well
that's five more four three two last one
very very good gave you one extra there
right we want to bring up
okay next is going to be a wide to
narrow squat alright let's add a little
bit of hop ready let's go so start white
tap down and go narrow that's one okay
good so keep your toes soft and always
keeping yourself on your toes okay light
and easy keep yourself lights good go
down low and tap very good bring your
butt down
very good there you go tap and look
straight ahead open up your chest nice
okay keep going
tap and tap
very good you are almost there okay you
have about five left let's go let's go
five good four three last two and last
one huh shake it out let's get down onto
the mat and let's work on lots of kicks
this workout were really target your
know what happed okay so heads by your
side relax leave your legs up show this
off slightly let's go one two three four
left and right is one okay good flutter
kicks
tighten the core very good remember it's
about bringing your shoulders off the
floor and aim to relax your neck keep
going nice huh phew your lower abs
that's five four three two and one
back up alright I told you I'm going to
be bringing the intensity up next it's
going to be a new to squat okay so study
in a new position and hop into a deep
squat get back down into nil and hop
good done two new and hop good all right
so push and use the momentum to bring
yourself up 30 repetitions no cheating
because
I can feel you all right so let's bring
it up good and then soft landing good
keep going you have 20 more okay keep
going
do not stop right now you're on workout
number nine very nice you have two more
exercises right after this keep going
the goal is three hundred and thirty
repetitions every single day for 30 days
ten more okay
up and down well push your butt up and
down good keep going down and up good
new whoa good last five more good for
more last three last two more come a hop
higher last one more hop and new down
plank position tank jacks okay so go
wider than the mat and Jack back in good
that's one okay let's go keep going
thirty plank Jack's within a breath out
who see you sweat dripping that's your
athlete and that is your fat cry okay
it's telling you that you have worked
hard and you deserve it for your body
last five four three two one
good last find a workout it's going to
be a plank rock and also dip but your
sweat slightly let's get into an elbow
plank all right one rock and one dip
good let's go whoo do you feel your core
your legs should be feeling like jelly
right now keep going okay so this will
work on your entire core muscles deep
side to side forward back and good
forward back and deep very good
look at his sweat dripping it is like
rain right now on the mat keep going
whoa you have ten or K that's eight more
that's six more plus four more plus two
more oh my god oh you can't feel me but
give me a high five
well then look at my sweat you have done
330 repetitions and I want you to
challenge yourself for the next 30 days
to repeat this workout every single day
okay feel like everything is just
melting right now it might be
challenging to begin with but keep that
momentum going keep that consistency
going and the workout will only get
easier
and once it's too easy guess what lift
some weights and challenge yourself okay
it's not just about the challenge but
rather it is about building discipline
and consistency into your lifestyle go
on take a friend challenge them to do
this workout with you get a workout
buddy to join you like this video share
this video and subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more workout
challenges and you can find out more in
my description box below all the best